nous sommes en mars 1761 Rousseau a 48
ans un conte hongrois se rend à Paris
pour rencontrer le célèbre philosophe
mais qui le reçoit un homme vêtu d'une
vieille robe de chambre et puis cette
robe de chambre est pleine de taches le
compte hongrois qui appartient à la
haute aristocratie est choqué par une
telle négligence mais les yeux de
l'homme dans la vieille robe de chambre
dégueulasse ses yeux ont une vivacité
extraordinaire c'est bien lui c'est le
philosophe dont tout le monde
parle
aujourd'hui ça passerait pour une petite
provocation mais se présenter à un
aristocrate avec autant de familiarité
au milieu du 18e siècle ça demande du
cran Rousseau se le permet parce que
c'est son personnage contrairement aux
autres grand noms des lumière pour lui
philosophe ça ne veut pas simplement
dire écrivain pour lui ça veut aussi
dire adopter un mode de vie particulier
le plus possible conforme à ses idées et
ça ça le rend fascinant déjà de son
vivant mais ce qui le rend surtout
fascinant pour pour nous c'est qu'il est
le penseur des lumières le plus influent
en Occident nous lui devons certaines de
nos idées les plus importantes dans
notre vision de la politique de la
justice sociale ou encore de l'éducation
son influence est si grande que certains
voient en lui le père involontaire des
pires idéologies en particulier des
totalitaristes Bertrand Russell dit par
exemple Hitler est un disciple de
Rousseau ouh là mais elles viennent d'où
ces idées si dangereuses et bien de la
vie exceptionnelle de Rousseau et je ne
dis pas exceptionnelle pour vous
persuader de regarder la vidéo il y a
tellement de choses folles dans sa vie
que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
sélectionner 10 anecdotes j'ai donc
ignoré les anecdotes les plus connues ni
Rousseau lui-même ni vos profs de lycée
ou d'université ne vous ont raconter ce
que vous allez découvrir dans mes 10
anecdotes si vous tenez à la légende de
Rousseau ne regardez pas cette vidéo
mais si vous voulez connaître la vérité
alors écoutez-moi jusqu'au
bout nous sommes au début du 18e siècle
Isaac Rousseau un orlogis Suisse vit
dans un quartier cosmopolite d'Istanbul
mais il est un immigré récent il a
laissé sa femme Suzanne et leur fils
François Rousseau à Genève et après 6
ans passés en Turquie il décid de
rentrer en Suisse juste après le décès
de sa belle-mère tiens tiens Isaac
reparaît donc à Genève en 1711 on
imagine les retrouvailles avec sa femme
leur second fils Jean-Jacques Rousseau
en est le fruit cette anecdote révèle le
caractère du père de Rousseau or ce
caractère déteindra sur son fils le père
transmettra d'abord son humeur
migratoire à son fils c'est vrai que les
jeunes etvoies de l'époque voyage
beaucoup en partie à cause des
difficultés économiques et Isaac
Rousseau lui n'a pas peur d'aller
s'installer en tur plus tard il vivra
dans différentes villes en Suisse il
refera sa vie parce que la mère du
philosophe est morte 10 jours après sa
naissance Jean-Jacques lui se déplacera
bien plus que son père après sa fugue à
16 ans il vivra entre la France l'Italie
la Suisse et même l'Angleterre il
déménagera au gris des opportunités et
de la censure un autre trait de
personnalité que le père transmet à son
fils c'est sa capacité à essayer de
nouvelles choses par exemple au début de
la vingtaine Isaac rousseo arrête
leorlogerie pour devenir prof de danse
mais finalement il revient à
l'horlogerie un an plus tard
Jean-Jacques sera bien plus touch Chatou
que son père il se passionnera pour la
musique le théâtre la botanique et bien
sûr la philosophie et la politique enfin
le père transmettra encore au fils son
sang chaud Isaac Rousseau s'emporte
facilement il est un peu une tête brûlée
ainsi il fuit Genève pour échapper à des
poursuites judiciaires quand
Jean-Jacques a 10 ans Jean-Jacques lui
ne sera pas violent comme il semble que
son père l' têté mais comme lui il
n'aura jamais peur du conflit y compris
avec les puissants et avec les personnes
dont il dépend c'est même pire comme son
père Jean-Jacques monte trop rapidement
sur ses grands chevaux il monte au
créneau pour un rien il est très
susceptible et il est déterminé à ne
jamais se laisser
[Musique]
faire Bernardin de Saint-Pierre l'auteur
du fameux roman romantique Paul et
Virginie était un ami proche de Rousseau
et il prétend que Rousseau lisait ce
livre Les Vies parallèles de plutarc à
seulement 2 ans et demi bien sûr et puis
il savait déjà lire dans le ventre de sa
mère alors c'est évidemment une légende
mais il y a une part de vérité derrière
cette légende Rousseau était un enfant
très précoce c'est vrai qu'il a appris à
lire très tôt ça s'explique par le fait
qu'il est né dans le milieu mileu des
artisans cultivés de Genève ces artisans
étaient instruits curieux de la
politique et de la gestion de leur cité
ils lisaient des romans mais aussi de la
vulgarisation scientifique du droit et
de l'histoire et puis bien sûr les
classiques comme les Vies parallèles de
plutarc qui sont les biographies des
grands hommes de l'antiquité
greco-romaine le titre vie parallèle
s'explique par le fait que plutar
raconte systématiquement la vie d'un
grec puis celle d'un romain qui lui
ressemble pour comparer leur destin ce
sont donc des couples de biographie le
plus célèbre étant le couple Alexandre
le Grand César si Rousseau lit aussitôt
c'est plus précisément parce que sa mère
était une femme cultivée et une grande
lectrice elle est morte à la naissance
de Rousseau mais elle a laissé beaucoup
de livres que son fils dévorera dans son
enfance et au départ il ne lit pas tout
seul son père qui était un de ces
artisans cultivés de Genève lit avec lui
le soir parfois toute la nuit c'est la
seule école qu'a connu Rousseau il est
probablement le plus génial autodidacte
de l'histoire il a appris à lire et il
aime lire donc il lira énormément quand
il aura accès à une bibliothèque et
qu'il aura le temps mais l'expérience
expérience décisive dans la formation de
sa culture philosophique c'est son
travail de Ghost Writer au début de la
trentaine il travaille pour Madame Dupin
une riche aristocrate et ardente
féministe elle a l'ambition d'écrire un
grand livre sur le rôle des femmes dans
l'histoire c'est pour cela que Rousseau
lit une centaine de livres d'histoire de
droit et de scienceces politique donc
pas des romans de gare et attention
Rousseau ne se contente pas de lire
comme ça parce que sa patronne elle veut
des résultats il fait ce que je ne cesse
de recommander sur cette chaîne et dans
mes emails il lit la plume à la main
c'est à dire en prenant des notes et
beaucoup de notes il abat donc un énorme
travail de lecture il noircit des
milliers de pages de notes avec les
meilleures idées les meilleures
citations des chronologies et cetera
Rousseau avait déjà beaucoup lu avant ce
travail mais après ce travail il a passé
un cap il a désormais la culture
intellectuelle d'un grand
[Musique]
penseur voici les toutes dernières
lignes écrites par Rousseau quelques
mois avant sa mort aujourd'hui il y a
précisément 50 ans de ma première
connaissance avec Madame de varins elle
avait 28 ans alors étant né avec le
siècle je n'en avais pas encore 17 ce
premier moment décida de moi pour toute
ma vie et produisit par un enchaînement
inévitable le destin du reste de mes
jours vieillard solitaire et malheureux
il repense à Madame de varins qui lui
avait dit pauvre petit quand tu seras
grand tu te souviendras de moi cette
femme qui l'a recueilli à la fin de
l'adolescence a joué le rôle de la mère
qu'il n'a jamais eu il l'appelait
d'ailleurs maman elle a tellement compté
pour lui qu'il l'a immort isé dans ses
fameuses confessions il en a même fait
un mythe le mythe de maman une femme au
Grand cœur qui tel une mère prend sous
sa protection un pauvre jeune homme qui
ne demande qu'à aimer mais la réalité
derrière le mythe n'est pas reluisante
bah oui on ne dit pas du mal de sa mère
la première chose c'est que madame de
Varin ne recueille pas Rousseau parce
qu'elle a un grand cœur mais parce
qu'elle est payée pour elle est financée
par le roi de sardigne pour convertir
des protestants au catholicisme il en
découle une autre réalité peu reluisante
si elle est payée pour convertir des
protestants au catholicisme elle ne peut
pas multiplier les aventures elle
risquerait de créer un scandale puis de
perdre son revenu donc si elle a une
relation avec Rousseau et s'il a
l'impression qu'elle n'est qu'à lui
c'est parce qu'elle n'a pas le choix
garder un jeune homme à convertir auprès
de soi c'est la manière la plus discrète
pour elle d'avoir un amant Rousseau est
bien déçu quand il découvre que Claude
Annet le jeune serviteur de madame de
varins joue en réalité le même rôle que
lui auprès d'elle sa maman a donc en
réalité deux amants qui vivent auprès
d'elle et puis Rousseau sera malheureux
quand un nouvel amant prendra sa place
autre réalité derrière le de maman elle
est une escroc elle a ruiné son mari et
elle s'est enfuie en ortant ce qu'elle
pouvait emporter la ruine du mari est
telle qu'il sera obligé de se cacher en
Angleterre la manque a remplacé Rousseau
surveiller les finances de Madame de
varins mais après son suicide
probablement de jalousie madame de
varins dépensera n'importe comment elle
multipliera les combines et les projets
foireux si bien qu'elle finira sa vie
dans la misère Rousseau l'aidera à
plusieurs reprises alors qu'il a
lui-même des moyens limité enfin
dernière réalité peu reluisante
concernant maman comme elle a un certain
talent pour mentir et pour cacher
l'argent que lui donne le roi de
sardigne ne rémunère pas seulement ses
efforts pour convertir des protestants
elle lui sert aussi et c'est peut-être
en fait son véritable rôle elle est
agent secret pour le roi de Sardaigne
elle disparaît ponctuellement pour
effectuer des missions nous n'en savons
rien puisque par définition elle est
agent secret et il semble même qu'elle
ait confié certaines missions à Rousseau
lui-même ce qui veut dire qu'il a une
petite expérience d'espion d'ailleurs à
l'époque Chambéry ù vit Rousseau avec
Madame de varins Chambéry est un nid
d'espion parce que c'est un carrefour
stratégique en Europe en entre la France
l'Italie et la
[Musique]
Suisse au début de la trentaine Rousseau
loge dans un hôtel parisien à table lors
des repas les hommes taquinent la jeune
lingère c'est-à-dire une servante qui
s'occupe du linge de l'hôtel les hommes
à tablés taquinent la jeune lingère au
point de lui faire venir les larmes aux
yeux Rousseau qui est très sensible
prend sa défense il se rapproche la
jeune lingère qui s'appelle thérè
devient son amante et puis avec le temps
elle devient sa compagne concrètement
elle est en même temps son amante et sa
gouvernante elle s'occupe de tout dans
son quotidien elle met de l'ordre
nettoie cuisine et cetera mais ce qui
est très étonnant c'est qu'elle est
infiniment moins intelligente que
Rousseau lui c'est un génie autodidacte
un polymatee un intellectuel ultra
cultivé elle c'est une servante je cite
le biographe à la limite de la débilité
elle sait à peine lire et écrire elle
est incapable de citer les mois de
l'année dans l'ordre je cite encore le
biographe son esprit est un désert le
contraste entre elle et Rousseau est tel
que les amis du philosophe conspireront
pour qu'ils se séparent ils échoueront
et didro en pleurera pourquoi pour
Rousseau fait-il de thérèe sa compagne
il y a bien sûr le confort domestique
thérèe prend soin de lui mais il y a une
chose moins avouable qui fait que
Rousseau trouve vraiment son compte dans
cette relation thérèe lui met des fessés
et oui Rousseau est masochiste il date
cette tendance d'un épisode de son
enfance que les confessions ont rendu
célèbre une femme qui s'occupait de son
éducation mademoiselle lamberciier lui
donne une fessée et Rousseau se rend
compte qu'il en tire du plaisir à la
fessé suivante c'est elle qui se rend
compte que quelque chose cloche et elle
arrêtera de lui en donner depuis
Rousseau cherchera des femmes pour
répéter cet épisode de son enfance à
l'adolescence il traîne au fond des
cours et dans les allées sombres et au
passage des filles il se déculotent
devant elle dans l'espoir que l'une
d'entre elles lui applique une
délicieuse fessée bien sûr ça rend sa
vie sentimentale compliquée mais Thérèse
elle accepte de faire ce qu'aucune autre
femme n'a accepté oui elle est presque
débile mais elle donne de bonnes
fessées une fois que Rousseau est une
star naturellement tout le monde veut le
voir mais comme toutes les stars il est
très peu disponible mais vous pouvez
faire une chose pour qu'il accepte de
vous rencontrer lui donner de la musique
à copier à l'époque les musiciens ne
peuvent pas photocopier ni imprimer
leurs partition donc ils les font copier
à la main ça demande une grande
précision une connaissance de la
notation musicale et une écriture claire
Rousseau a ses compéten et en plus il a
le sens moral d'un artisan c'est-à-dire
qu'il aime le travail bien fait il
travaille un peu plus lentement que les
autres copistes mais très soigneusement
ses copies sont impeccables du coup son
tarif est un peu plus élevé sauf que
beaucoup de clients n'en ont rien à
faire de le leur commande ils veulent
simplement approcher le célèbre écrivain
même les personnes les plus
prestigieuses doivent en passer par là
mais pourquoi Rousseau se fait-il chier
à copier de la musique à l'époque un
écrivain aussi célèbre que lui peut
largement vivre de sa plume c'est vrai
que les éditions pirates réduisent
considérablement les droits d'auteur
mais en général un auteur à succès
trouve un messen qui le met à l'abri du
besoin oui mais voilà en acceptant
l'argent d'autrui on devient redevable
on n plus libre et ça Rousseau le refuse
absolument une des valeurs les plus
importantes pour lui et peut-être même
la valeur la plus importante c'est
l'indépendance et l'indépendance
garantit la liberté Rousseau protège
tout d'abord sa liberté intellectuelle
j'ai toujours senti dit-il que l'État
d'auteur n'était ne pouvait être
illustre et respectable qu'autant qu'il
n'était pas un métier il est trop
difficile de penser noblement quand on
ne pense que pour vivre mais il protège
aussi sa liberté morale Rousseau a été
domestique à plusieurs reprises dans sa
jeunesse et il a terriblement souffert
dans cette condition c'est carrément un
traumatisme Rousseau ne veut plus jamais
avoir à obéir à un quelconque supérieur
il ne veut plus jamais dépendre d'un
autre homme cela le conduira à des refus
qui paraîtront choquants et même
égoïstes par exemple Louis XV veut le
rencontrer après avoir apprécié son
opéra le Devin du village ce qui
signifie que le roi veut lui donner une
pension pour Rousseau cette récompense
représente à la fois la fin de la
pauvreté et le prestige artistique et
pourtant il refuse 2 jours après le
refus didro va voir Rousseau et
l'engueule violemment mais rien y fait
Rousseau veut rester indépendant c'est
si important pour lui que dans la foulée
il démissionne de l'emploi alimentaire
qu'il avait obtenu grâce à sa notoriété
il vivra donc exclusivement en copiant
de la musique il sera pauvre mais libre
et son amour de l'indépendance grandira
encore avec les années à partir de la
cinquantaine lorsque commenceront ses
ennuis avec les autorités et l'opinion
publique Rousseau est si susceptible
qu'il refuse le moindre cadeau une
bouteille de vin un bon plat il
n'accepte rien il gâche pas mal d'amitié
en soupçonnant ses proches de vouloir le
corrompre pardon pour l'interruption
mais j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent mais sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 heur dans
une journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuel connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvre
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations et
dans les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo nous sommes en 1749 Rousseau a
donc 37 ans son ami didro un autre grand
philosophe des Lumières le maître
d'œuvre de la fameuse encyclopédie didro
est en prison à Vincen les autorités
l'accusent d'avoir critiqué la religion
officielle comme Rousseau est pauvre et
qu'à l'époque il n'y a pas le RER c'est
à pied qu'il va voir didro à la prison
de Vincen à l'est de la capitale cet été
il fait très chaud le soleil tape pour
marcher moins vite et donc moins sué
Rousseau emporte une revue qu'il lit sur
le chemin il y trouve la question du
concours de l'Académie de Dijon si le
rétablissement des sciences et des arts
a contribué à épurer les mœurs pour
faire simple c'est un peu un concours de
dissertation pour les intellectuels et
quand Rousseau lit le sujet de
l'Académie de Dijon si le rétablissement
des sciences et des arts a contribué à
épurer les murs il a une révélation il
est en trans toutes ses lectures toutes
ses réflexions fusionnent en lui et
suggèrent des images pour répondre à la
question de l'Académie non seulement
Rousseau gagne le concours mais il
devient une star du jour au lendemain
pour l'expliquer avec une expression de
notre époque son texte devient viral
tout le monde en parle d'innombrables
compte-rendus commentaires ou
réfutations sont publiés le fond du
discours de Rousseau est donc très
contesté mais ce qui fait l'unanimité
c'est le style de Rousseau il écrit si
bien dit ses adversaires qu'il peut
persuader le lecteur de n'importe quoi
effectivement le style de Rousseau est
un des plus beaux de la langue française
ses idées elles ne sont pas nouvelles
l'opposition entre la science et la
vertu est un débat classique et Rousseau
puise dans plein de références connues
mais comme souvent dans l'histoire des
idées on attribue leur paternité à celui
qui a le talent pour les populariser
madame de style une des femmes de
lettres françaises les plus célèbres du
19e siècle dira Rousseau n'a rien
découvert mais il a tout enflammé la
notoriété qu'il gagne avec son Discours
sur les sciences et les arts est si
grande et si rapide qu'il fait beaucoup
de jaloux et parmi ceux qui connaissent
les circonstances de la rédaction du
discours certains posent une question
est-ce vraiment Rousseau le génie à
l'origine de ce succès intellectuel et
oui parce que si Rousseau a découvert le
sujet du concours de l'Académie de Dijon
en allant voir didro et bien il lui en a
parlé d'où la thèse de certains le
véritable génie intellectuel est
derrière le discours sur les et les arts
c'est didro sans didro pas de Rousseau
ça c'est vrai sans didro pas de Rousseau
ils se rencontrent au tout début de la
trentaine ils ont quasiment le même âge
et c'est le coup de foudre intellectuel
il passe beaucoup de temps ensemble il
discute tout le temps il joue aux échecs
mais la vérité c'est que didro parle
beaucoup plus c'est un peu un monologue
à deux didro qui est brillant et
objectivement plus brillant que Rousseau
didro est un peu son coach intellectuel
il l'aide à développer et clarifier ses
idées il stimule donc intellectuellement
Rousseau mais est-ce vraiment didro qui
lui donne l'idée de répondre à la
question de l'Académie de Dijon en
prenant le contrepied de l'opinion
commune c'est-à-dire en critiquant les
sciences et les arts non Rousseau avait
bien compris que la plupart des
candidats allaient faire l'éloge des
sciences et des arts et donc il était
impossible de se distinguer en prenant
le même angle didro ne fait que
confirmer ce choix mais c'est vrai qu'il
a encouragé Rousseau Rousseau hésite à
participer au concours parce qu'il doute
de ses capacités c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le syndrome de l'imposteur
mais didro l'encourage et le
conseille au début de la cinquantaine
Rousseau réside à Motier dans le canton
de nechatel au nord-ouest de la Suisse
actuelle un vendredi c'est la foire de
la ville au milieu de la nuit la maison
de Rousseau est bombardée d'une grêle de
Pierre une des pierres casse les vitres
de la cuisine et roule jusqu'au pied du
lit elle fait presque 2 kg on n plus
dans l'insulte c'est carrément un
attentat cette anecdote explique l'état
d'esprit de Rousseau à la fin de sa vie
à partir de la cinquantaine il est mort
à 66 ans oui il est ultra susceptible
voire fou il est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui complotiste c'est-à-dire
qu'il explique tout ce qui lui arrive
par un complot mais mettez-vous à sa
place vous dormez paisiblement dans
votre lit et des fous furieux vous
lancent des pierres de 2 kg qui
atterrissent au pied de votre lit oui
Rousseau est complotiste mais il n'est
pas devenu complotiste en passant ses
nuits sur Internet il est complotiste
parce qu'il est persécuté les autorités
de plusieurs gouvernements veulent le
mettre en prison et des excités passent
près de l'assassiner ses persécutions
commencent quand il a 50 ans avec
l'apparution de l'émil sont traités
d'éducation ce livre crée le scandale
pour ses propos sur la religion Rousseau
affirme que la religion est une affaire
de sentiment que Dieu est dans la
conscience dans le cœur de l'homme du
coup tous les intermédiaires sont
inutiles pour être un véritable chrétien
Rousseau discrétite totalement les
institutions religieuses donc forcément
elles ne vont pas lui taper dans la main
mais s'il n'y avait que ça Rousseau a
aussi contre lui une partie des
philosophes autrement dit il s'est mis
tout le monde à dos les partisans de la
religion et les partisans de la raison
et il a notamment pour adversaire le
plus fameux partisan de la raison
Voltaire d'ailleurs j'ai déjà fait une
vidéo sur la vie de Voltaire si ça vous
intéresse le complotisme de Rousseau
c'est est en parti la faute de Voltaire
avant que Rousseau ne soit célèbre et
dans les premiers temps de sa célébrité
leur relation est plutôt bonne il
collabor même pour la réécriture d'une
comédie balai de Voltaire la princesse
de Navar ils n'ont pas les mêmes idées
mais ils Contin continuent d'échanger
une fois que Rousseau est un écrivain de
premier plan mais au bout d'un moment
Voltaire ne peut plus tolérer que
Rousseau critique la civilisation en
particulier le divertissement la
dernière goutte c'est lorsque Rousseau
prend position contre l'établissement
des théâtres à Genève dans sa fameuse
lettre sur les spectacles Voltaire qui
est un grand auteur de théâtre fait batt
ti au même moment un théâtre privé dans
sa propriété situé à la frontière de la
Suisse à ses yeux Rousseau fait alliance
avec l'Église or l'ami de mon ennemi et
mon ennemi Voltaire passe son temps à se
battre contre les superstitions
religieuses il ne peut pas accepter que
Rousseau tire contre le camp de la
raison et le problème c'est que quand on
devient l'ennemi de Voltaire c'est
vraiment la guerre Voltaire ne recule
devant rien pour gagner et avec Rousseau
il va vraiment trop loin à plusieurs
reprises d'autres philosophes le lui
disent il déterent des affaires dans le
passé de Rousseau et les rend public il
répand de fausses rumeurs il écrit des
pflet de faux textes pour discréditer
Rousseau et il semble qu'il ait même
encouragé les autorités à le persécuter
et qu'il les ayit même aidé comment
s'étonner que Rousseau soit complotiste
comment se sent-on quand on est
persécuté par l'intellectuel le plus
influent d'Europe de surcroix
milliardairire Rousseau ne ferme pas
l'œil il passe ses nuits à imaginer les
machinations de Voltaire et des autres
il soupçonne tout le monde y compris et
surtout ceux qui l'aent de bon cœur par
exemple il attaque David yum un des plus
grands philosophes britanniques des
lumières il attaque David yum alors même
qu'il l'a aidé contre la vie de ses amis
à s'installer en Angleterre et qui lui a
même obtenu une pension royale mais
comme un chien battu Rousseau n'arrive
plus à faire
confiance dans l'histoire de la
littérature occidentale il n'est pas
rare qu'un livre commence à se vendre
bien après sa publication à la fin de la
vie de l'auteur ou même après sa mort et
inversement un livre peut connaître un
immense succès à sa sortie puis être
oublié par les générations de lecteur
suivante par exemple vous savez qui a
écrit le bestseller français du 18e
siècle et bien c'est Rousseau et oui il
n'est pas que que philosophe au milieu
de la quarantaine Rousseau a envie
d'écrire un roman c'est vrai qu'il a
critiqué les romans mais il a vraiment
envie d'en écrire un et puis il peut
s'en servir pour faire passer ses idées
morales ça donne Julie ou la nouvelle
elloïse ce roman épistolaire raconte
l'histoire d'amour d'une jeune
aristocrate Julie et de son précepteur
saintpreux une fois séparé Julie épouse
un homme bien plus âgé qu'elle monsieur
de volmart puis elle choisit d'assumer
ses devoirs d'épouse et de mère malgré
son amour pour son ancien précepteur ce
roman n'est pas un succès mais un
véritable le triomphe les exemplaires
s'enlèvent comme des petits pains et les
éditions pirates se multiplient certains
libraires lancent même un business de
location du roman on paye à l'heure et
il faut lire le roman debout dans la
boutique pendant que d'autres attendent
leur tour l'histoire plaît à un public
très large au-delà des hommes de lettre
et de la noblesse c'est toute la
bourgeoisie francophone qui admire Julie
ou la nouvelle elloïse une foule
d'anonymes écrivent à Rousseau pour lui
dire ce qu'ils ont ressenti les
personnages du roman ont une énorme
influence inspiré par le bonheur
familial décrit par Rousseau des paires
de famille reprennent goût à a une vie
qu'il jugeait monotone instruit par
l'exemple de saintpreux des séducteurs
décident de lever le pied Rousseau
devient un peu le prophète des âmes
sensibles admirative de son
sentimentalisme les auteurs romantiques
estimeront que leur rapport à
l'existence est déjà dans Julie ou la
nouvelle elloïse mais ça c'était il y a
deux siècles aujourd'hui ce livre se
vend peu et ne fait pas partie des
grands romans de la littérature
française j'ai compris pourquoi en le
lisant il y a une dizaine d'années c'est
très long répétitif et on a l'impression
que Rousseau nous fait une leçon de
morale bien sûr le style est magnifique
mais ce roman est éclipsé par les textes
philosophiques c'est dans ces textes que
Rousseau exprime son
génie chez Monsieur de Gérardin le
dernier rô de Rousseau l'éducation des
enfants est surprenant eux qui sont des
aristocrates ils ont tout le loisir de
courir dans les champs et dans les bois
avec les enfants du village leur père
les contraint aussi à de longues marches
pour déjeuner ils doivent aller
décrocher la nourriture au sommet d'un
poteau en bois glissant ce qu'on appelle
un M de Cocagne mais c'est quoi cette
éducation et bien c'est l'éducation de
Rousseau monsieur de Girardin est fan de
l'Émile le traité d'éducation de
Rousseau et il n'est pas le seul ce
traité d'éducation a déjà une énorme
influence à l'époque de Rousseau par
exemple des mères préfèrent allaitter
elles-même leur nourrisson ell le
baignent dans l'eau froide
malheureusement il y a parfois des
drames avec les disciples trop ailés qui
veulent élever leur nouveau né à la dure
l'éducation de l'Émile consiste à
laisser les enfants interagir avec la
nature et apprendre de leurs expériences
plutôt que de les soumettre à une
discipline précoce à l'époque cette
philosophie enthousiasme beaucoup de
gens mais beaucoup estiment aussi que
c'est une une utopie imaginée par la
personne la moins légitime qui soit pour
parler d'éducation et oui parce que vous
le savez peut-être Rousseau a avoué dans
ses confessions avoir abandonné les cinq
enfants qu'il a eu avec Thérèse mais cet
aveu est un mystère selon certains c'est
un mensonge de Rousseau il veut
dissimuler son masochisme ou son
impuissance et puis ça rend aussi ses
confessions très authentiques en effet
il est né avec une malformation de la
vessie et de l'urêtre si bien qu'il a
souvent envie d'uriné d'où en partie son
amour des balades en forêt et la
malformation le rend peut-être aussi
impuissant mais ce qui rend cette
hypothèse peu crédible c'est qu'il était
courant d'abandonner ses enfants à
l'époque que Rousseau pauvre non marié
et ambitieux avait toutes les raisons de
le faire qu'il avait déjà confessé
l'abandon à plusieurs amis et enfin
qu'il avait exprimé des remords dans des
lettres à thérè mais en même temps des
personnes ont enquêté pour retrouver les
enfants ou les preuves de l'abandon et
elles n'ont rien retrouvé alors mensonge
ou vérité personnellement je ne sais pas
et je ne penche même pas vers l'une ou
l'autre version ce qui est certain en
revanche c'est que l'Émile a changé la
vision de l'enfance en Occident c'est en
bonne partie grâce à Rousseau que les
parents pensent aujourd'hui que leur
enfant doit se développer
[Musique]
naturellement Napoléon aurait dit devant
la tombe de Rousseau avant qu'il n'entre
au Panthéon c'est lui qui a préparé la
Révolution française en effet Rousseau
est un des pèir spirituel de la
Révolution française ses idées il
trouvent un écho considérable chez les
révolutionnaires français Rousseau passe
pour le champion des droits de l'homme
l'âme des nouvelles constitutions à la
fois prophète et martyre ce sont surtout
les idées du contrat social qui n'était
pourtant pas le livre le plus connu de
Rousseau ce sont les idées de ce livre
qui inspire l'agitation politique de
l'époque le pacte social la souveraineté
populaire la religion civile Rousseau
est aussi le héros de grandes fêtes
officielles et patriotiques lors de la
fête du triomphe du 14 juillet 1790 par
exemple on promène un buste en pierre de
Rousseau devant les ruines de la Bastie
il n'est plus un philosophe mais un
mythe de 1790 à 1792 la nation lui voou
un véritable culte plus personne n'est
contre le penseur qui s'était mis tout
le monde à dos mais en réalité la S
tification de Rousseau a commencé après
sa mort les voyageurs se rendent dans
les lieux qu'il a habité il touche ses
reliques ses sabots sa tabatière que des
riches essaient d'arracher à prix d'or
un jeune inconnu malade d'amour vient se
suicider dans la dernière demeure de
Rousseau en demandant à y être enterré
Rousseau devient l'objet d'une véritable
industrie
touristique si vous aimez l'esprit de
cette vidéo à savoir découvrir des
choses intéressantes en allant à
l'essentiel et sans se prendre la tête
alors vous aimerez probablement mon
programme Culture Express c'est un
programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en
seulement quelques mois il couvre tous
les domaines de la culture générale vous
maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l'histoire de
l'humanité sur l'histoire de France en
économie en science politique en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et en philosophie
vous ne serez plus jamais à cours de
choses à dire et vous gagnerez la
confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstance vous pouvez en savoir
plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxens m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinents et je trouve
que tu as trouvé la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioriture vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma sœur qui
travaille comme diplommate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusé vous
verrez d'autres témoignages comme ceci
dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme et si vous vous inscrivez
vous bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat
une fois que vous aurez terminé le
programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore tapez
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée